we've just had this update for the
Metropolitan Police at around 20 past
four so just over half an hour ago the
color you're seeing here on your screen
crashed into the gates of Downing Street
uh this video clearly taken
um a few moments after it happened
because we understand now that White
Hall is called and off traffic being
turned away from that area what we do
know about what happened is that nobody
was injured armed officers arrested a
man at the scene and we're told by the
Metropolitan Police on suspicion of
criminal damage and dangerous driving
Metropolitan Police say inquiries are
ongoing so this happening literally
within the last half an hour We're
sending our correspondence from
Westminster down to the scene and to see
what more information they can get but
obviously as Matthew was just saying A
Downing Street um probably one of the
most heavily guarded streets in London
Matthew and you were referring to this
video before we brought it to our
viewers um because it's uh it's on the
social media and we've managed to get
hold of it to bring it to people you
haven't got access to social media at
the moment
um and and you can just see the movable
barriers in front of the permanent
barriers in front of Downing Street you
know it's a heavily secured area and for
a car to do that you know
there's going to be serious questions
asked as to what the intent was and how
it was allowed to happen exactly I mean
I suppose that's that's exactly the
video I was referring to and that's the
point I was trying to make you can see
there it's quite clear and as I say
anyone who knows dining Street and many
of us walk past it quite frequently uh
you can see that actually to get itself
into that position requires quite a bit
of maneuvering it has to actually turn
off the main road on Whitehall get past
a couple of those
um those silver temporary barriers and
then you know there's there's five or
six meters before it then reaches the
gates of dining street so as I as I say
look we can't we shouldn't we shouldn't
speculate it's possible someone swerved
in there but it does given the position
of that silver car as you can see
questions you rightly say should be
raised about exactly what it's doing
there in the first place and I think it
is interesting that police are telling
us that they have arrested a man on
suspicion of criminal damage and
dangerous driving and obviously as I say
due process will take its course it's
not up to us to decide what what this
man's intentions were but it is
revealing that that's what police are
now telling us because it's not a
natural position for a car to be but
also what I was trying to say you can
see very clearly there in in those
images